[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa con más romeros a la mar este
domingo que ya viene en dos días se
conmemora el aniversario de la
erradicación de la viruela cómo se logró
este y tomar buenos días raúl
efectivamente el 8 de mayo de
1980 fue que la organización mundial de
la salud anunció que el mundo estaba
libre de la viruela es por eso que por
ejemplo pues creo que ni tú ni yo
tenemos esas la marchita que éramos la
tienda desmarca claro en mis padres
también es la primera vez y la única vez
en la historia que se ha logrado
erradicar una enfermedad y eso de la
mano de la primera vacuna de la historia
vamos a repasar las fechas principales
que vamos a contar hoy en este viaje
histórico que ya sabes que tanto me
gusta los intentos para inmunizar contra
la viruela una enfermedad devastadora
desde hace siglos empezaron hace mucho
tiempo incluso en el siglo 11 hay
pruebas de que unos monjes budistas en
china lo que hacía era aspirar por la
nariz costras de la enfermedad de que
provocaba esta de las heridas que
provoca la enfermedad para inmunizarse
una práctica llamada vario lización que
se extendió por todo el mundo y que se
seguía usando hasta los años 2007 y el
siglo 18 que pasó después que en 1796
finalmente se inventó esa primera vacuna
luego detallaremos cómo empezaron las
campañas de vacunación en todo el mundo
con amplios desafíos logísticos también
por ejemplo para llevarlo al continente
americano que también vamos a explicar
cómo sucedió esto y gracias a todas
estas campañas de vacunaciones masivas
en la década de los 50 se radica en lo
que llamamos el norte global pero no es
hasta 1980 que se radican todo el mundo
con unos unas cosas que nos resultan un
poco lo que sucedió y también con la
distribución inequitativa de las vacunas
no tardaron 30 años más en desaparecer
esta enfermedad en los países del sur
global mientras que en los del norte
pues en alrededor de los 50 ya estaba ya
estaba radicada pero igualmente es la
historia al final de un hito histórico
global así es mal pero además entonces
el impacto que realmente tenía la
viruela pues por suerte muchos ahora no
tenemos que recordar lo devastadora que
era una enfermedad que ha matado desde
faraones hasta el imperio inca al jefe
del imperio inca también haría segunda
de inglaterra murió de viruela o sea ha
causado muerte y devastación a lo largo
de siglos en todos los continentes tenía
un 30% de tasa de mortalidad es decir
que tres de cada diez personas que
contraen la enfermedad se morían a se
estima que en los peores picos de la
enfermedad podía matar hasta siete de
cada mil habitantes en europa y sólo en
el siglo 20 murieron 300 millones de
personas unos 5 millones anuales es
decir que es una especie de emergencia
de kobe 19 eterna que lo asistió a lo
largo del tiempo para que veamos cómo
llegó a desarrollarse esa vacuna marc
pues es la historia de un científico
inglés que se dio cuenta de que las
personas que ordeñaban las vacas no se
contagiaban y consideró que era por una
especie de primo de la vacuna de la
viruela perdón del virus de la viruela
que se llamaba la viruela vacuna de
hecho de ahí viene el nombre la
etimología de la palabra vacuna lo que
hizo fue este virus lo inyectó en
un niño se dio cuenta de que este niño
luego lo expuso la viruela y no se
contagiaba y básicamente en eso
consistió y luego fue lo que se hicieron
estas vacunas obligatorias
en reino unido la primera vacuna
obligatoria fue esta en 1850 y cómo
llegó esta vacuna a nuestro continente
la verdad es una historia verdaderamente
lo que hay un desafío logístico era muy
difícil hacerlo largas distancias porque
lo que se hacía era material de
una herida para luego pasarlo a otra
persona era la única manera de
transportar esta vacuna muy rudimentaria
entonces lo que se hizo fue 12
niños huérfanos en una expedición que
salió desde españa desde la coruña en
1803 y llegó a venezuela caracas
1804 y van infectando en cadena a estos
niños para que el último niño al final
cuando se desembarcará en el continente
americano tuviera las heridas listas
para sacarlas y poder vacunar al resto
de la población americana una cosa que
pues dejando de lado a los múltiples
dilemas éticos que tiene fue un éxito
logístico y el aprendizaje de este hito
de la ciencia y la riqueza de la viruela
marc pues básicamente en dos años
después de este 40 aniversario podemos
recuperar unas palabras que dijo el
director de la organización mundial de
la salud
y ahora que el mundo se enfrenta a la
pandemia del joven 19 la victoria de la
humanidad sobre la viruela es un
recordatorio de lo que es posible cuando
los países se unen para combatir una
amenaza de salud común está misma
solidaridad basada en la unidad es la
que necesitamos más que nunca para
vencer al cob 19 cobit nineteen y de
esta manera más llegamos al final de
este espacio de salud por esta semana
gracias como